last question today hey David in your TJ
Kirk amazing atheist interview he talked
about considering social media as if it
is a government entity that cannot
restrict speech unless it is illegal it
wasn't clear if you supported it you
don't actually think the government
should force private companies to
publish content they don't want to do
you know I don't so my view is that if
you want to argue that certain social
media platforms have become so
ubiquitous that they should be treated
as though they are sort of governmental
in how speech laws should apply to them
then you need to actually legislate that
there is legal infrastructure dating
back to the mid 60s that would determine
when a platform has reached that status
I don't believe that that's something
that should be done I'm against that as
the quote solution to the problem of
speech on social networks and media
platforms but what I what I do think is
that if you are someone who supports
that you need to establish that legally
through the legal infrastructure that
exists that's not my solution that's not
what I want done but if you are someone
who wants that done then we know exactly
what needs to happen legally I don't
think that that's the solution I am okay
I think that it's perfectly reasonable
you know there's this movement now to
say how can you say you're for Business
Regulation but all of a sudden now you
think Facebook should be able to do
whatever they want if there's speech
they don't like like Alex Jones speech
on the other side there's those on the
Left who look at the right and they say
how can you say you are for businesses
being able to do whatever they want if
now you're saying Facebook should be
forced to publish Alex Jones's content
there these are two different issues
right we're talking about what is legal
under the what decisions are legal for
businesses to make and then what
decisions are illegal for businesses to
make like saying we are not going to
allow black customers
or Jewish customers that would be an
illegal decision do I think that it's a
great thing for platforms to be banning
lots of content wholesale no I don't
think it's a great thing big picture did
Alex Jones clearly violate the Terms of
Service of the platforms from which he
got banned absolutely the problem is the
selective enforcement because there are
way smaller content creators than Alex
Jones who do the exact same stuff and
they've not been banned arguably because
they're completely under the radar and
that's the concern I have none of these
companies did anything illegal and all
of these companies are more than
entitled more than entitled to have
Terms of Service and to enforce them if
you don't believe that then you have to
establish legally that they should be
regulated in terms of speech the way the
government is regulated I don't think
that's the solution send me your
thoughts if you disagree we have a
fantastic bonus show today we will talk
about the economy we will talk about
Pluto we will also talk about the most
and least valuable college degrees all
of that and more on today's bonus show
look forward to speaking to you then